[Music]
when you feel that you can't fight it
you just go with it don't be afraid to
fail and you don't want to block the
pain too much
without the pain what will we talk about
there will be times when your best isn't
good enough there can be many reasons
for this but as long as you give your
best you'll be okay
did you get straight A's in school
if so good for you congratulations
but in the real world you'll never get
straight A's again
there are ups and there are Downs
and what I want to say to you today is
that it's okay
rejection Might Sting but my feeling is
that often it has very little to do with
you loyalty betrayal love
all those things are there the price in
this world is a little more harsh
my father is a great artist
I'm not an authority on my father but I
knew he was a great artist and I I've
always loved his work I'm very partial
to it and it was very it's very
important to continue his legacy
he was a loving father he wasn't a he
wasn't a father took me out to play
baseball or those kind of things but he
in his own way was very as I say loving
and then and
um his intentions were good
and then later I got much more
appreciative and more uh realized how
special he was and you take your parents
for granted sometimes and I wish I had
been more curious about him and and I I
regret that deeply I was busy myself so
I wasn't really I said yeah yeah not to
myself and so I wanted to make a
documentary about uh so about my father
so that the kids
and my grandkids his great grandkids
could would know who their who he was
what he was about when he passed away
about 20 years ago so I wanted the kids
to see it when they got older and I
appreciate what their grandfather did
again well well all I say to the kids is
that you know whenever you need to talk
to me I'm always here I try and I
reiterate that from time to time and say
you have you know not half yet you ask
me I'm here always and I never say I'm
not going to be here one day but I will
say that eventually
but they have to like know that I'm
there and take advantage of it
because I'm their father you know and
sometimes we have talks and this and
that but to get to real important
questions about stuff
you would hope that they would
come to you and try to get into some of
that in whatever way they want to try
and do it
that it's probably not comfortable but
it's important when it comes to the Arts
passion should always Trump common sense
you aren't just following dreams you're
reaching for your destiny you're a
dancer a singer a choreographer a
musician a filmmaker a writer a
photographer a director a producer an
actor an artist that's not a bad place
to start
now that you've made your choice or
rather succumbed to it your path is
clear
not easy but clear power doesn't come
from the title the power comes from
trust respect Vision work and again
collaboration
you'll probably be hard on yourself than
any director
I'm not going to tell you to go easy on
yourselves I assume you didn't pick the
slide because you thought it would be
easy
I can tell you some of the things I tell
my own children and as corny as it
sounds I tell them don't be afraid to
fail I urge them to take chances to keep
an open mind to welcome new experiences
and new ideas you do the best you can
with your children you do the best you
can making movies at a certain point you
just have to let both of them go and
hope for the best
it's up to the audiences to decide if
it's entertainment the critics to decide
if it's good and ultimately posterity to
the side of its Army just be calm when
things are going well
be calm don't think you're on top of the
world in the sense you always got to be
wary because I've seen it I've seen
people come I've seen people go I've
seen them come I've seen them go you got
to be chilled you got to like just take
what's good in your life and move
forward cautiously and carefully and and
thank God that you that you have that
just it's very very important not to to
overextend yourself when you're when you
think you you know you've gotta it's no
such thing everybody's dispensable
you're never satisfied and there's
always a problem always something to
overcome there's no such thing as I
think well if things would be easy
they'd be easy then what there's always
a problem there's no way around it
that's my life and sometimes the
problems need to be created in order to
solve that problem
um it's one that has to be addressed
finally though it's always been lurking
or there somewhere and now finally it
comes to the fore it's time for it to
come
rejection Might Sting but my feeling is
that often it has very little to do with
you when you're auditioning or pitching
the director or producer or investor may
just have something or someone different
in mind that's just how it is listen to
yourself
I'm mostly going to talk about these I
these ideas in movie active terms but I
think this applies to all of you you'll
find comparable situations in all the
disciplines the way the director gets to
be right is you help him or her be right
you may start out with different ideas
the director will have a vision you will
have ideas about your character as an
actor you always want to be true to your
character and be true to yourself
but the bottom line is you've got the
part
and that's very important
you're lucky if you're if you're working
all the time and being asked and then
it's a matter of what you do with what
you have
personally I always try to listen
because I might be not and maybe I'm not
getting something I always try and take
everybody's because it's important to
listen to everyone as many people as you
can and get their input but then finally
you have to make your own decision about
what you're going to do and that's it
that's what you feel and that's it and
that that's the most important thing
um
I I think the most important thing
because that's where the uniqueness
comes in because it's you you've done it
it's your thing it's not anybody else's
it's your choice
right and there's wrong and there's
common sense and there's abuse of power
[Music]
and as a citizen I have as much right as
anybody an actor an athlete a musician
anybody else to voice my opinion and if
I have a bigger voice because of my
situation I'm going to use it whenever I
see a blatant abuse of power
foreign